[Music]
welcome back
all right so we're talking about vector
calculus div grad and curl
divergence gradient and
rotation of your vector field today i'm
talking about the gradient
okay and notice that i have already
gotten too lazy to include my little
over bars
i'm basically going to drop these but we
know that this operator
is a vector of partial derivatives so
the grad operator is partial partial x
partial partial y in two dimensions
if in three dimensions there would be a
partial partial z
i'm going to make my life easy and for
now just look at it in 2d
and the gradient of a scalar function f
so if i have some scalar
[Music]
f of x and y just recall
that the gradient of f sometimes this is
also called
grad of f
is a vector field so it takes a scalar
and creates a vector field
partial f partial x partial
f partial y so when you hit
grad with an f you literally just put in
f here
so if i had grad f there would be an f
here
and you would apply the partial partial
x to f and the partial partial y to
f and you would have those in the two
the two components of your vector output
very simple to compute
we could create an example for example
if f
was i don't know x squared
plus y squared
then the gradient of f
is going to be the partial of this with
respect to x
which is 2x in the first component and
the partial of this with respect to y
in the second component to y
and essentially what that's going to do
if i plot that as a vector field
in x and y where maybe this is the
origin
what we're going to have is as x
and y get bigger this vector field gets
bigger in the x direction
so it starts off small in the x
direction and gets bigger and bigger
if i start in the y direction for larger
y
it gets bigger and bigger and similarly
on the diagonals the farther i go it
gets bigger and bigger
in kind of all of the directions
so very very intuitive easy to compute
for a given scalar function x squared
plus y squared this kind of makes sense
because this function also gets bigger
and bigger
as i get higher in radius x squared plus
y squared literally
uh is like a big paraboloid
if i look down you know on this kind of
x
y and if i look down on that in this
x y coordinates it kind of makes sense
that my gradient increases
as i go farther away because this gets
steeper and steeper
okay so that's how you compute the
gradient this is kind of mathematically
what it is
a couple of interesting properties here
the gradient is a linear
operator in fact this nabla operator
this del operator in general is a linear
operator
so grad
is linear
which specifically means that if i take
the gradient
of some function f1
plus another function f2 it equals
the gradient of f1 plus the gradient of
f2 and you can convince yourself that
this is true
because basically if i had you know f1
plus
f2 i would take the partial of the sum
of them
on in both rows and the partial
derivative is a linear operator so
partial of f1 plus f2 is partial of
f1 plus partial of f2 so you can verify
that this is true
and also that the gradient of some
constant a times f is that constant
times
the gradient of f so this is really
important linearity means that
superposition holds if i write down a
differential equation in terms of the
gradient operator
it's a linear differential equation and
superposition will hold
if i have two solutions and i add those
solutions there's still a solution
when you add them together so linearity
is a really important property for
differential equations and for operators
in general
and i just want to point out that the
gradient is in fact a linear operator
okay a couple more examples of the
gradient this is one that i've given you
a few times but i really like it
so if i take the gradient of a
temperature field t
of x and y
and let's say that that temperature
field is going from
uh hotter to colder
okay let's say maybe um i have a blow
torch and i
i this is a metal plate and i hit this
with a blow torch for
10 seconds and then i let it go so it's
hot in the middle cold on the outside
the gradient of this temperature will be
a vector at every point i will have a
grad
t and that grad t is a vector of
uh partial t partial x
and partial t partial y it will
literally have an
arrow direction telling me how fast that
temperature changes in the x
and y directions and every point
it will point in the direction of the
maximum rate of change
so the gradient of temperature tells me
what direction is locally the fastest
way to climb
that temperature gradient it's kind of
why the name
uh stuck and so i always like to give a
homework question or an exam question to
my students and i think they all think
i'm crazy
which is okay you're an ant flying
around in a room and you're cold
or sorry ants don't fly you're a bee
flying around in a room and you're cold
and there's a heat source in what
direction do you fly
to get there as fast as possible and if
they have the temperature distribution
all they have to do is compute the
gradient
at that b's location right now and
they'll go
towards that as fast as possible again i
mentioned earlier this is how
we optimize functions in lots of
optimization problems mathematically is
by gradient descent
i would literally take steps along the
gradient direction until i climb this
hill
and that's a pretty fast efficient way
of finding the optimum value the maximum
or the minimum
of a function that's how we train
machine learning algorithms like deep
neural networks with stochastic
gradient descent exact same gradient
okay
sometimes it's a bee flying around in a
room sometimes it's a billy goat
trying to climb a mountain as fast as
possible that billy goat still computes
the gradient
of the altitude to climb as fast as
possible okay
good um a few other things i want to
point out
you can use this gradient to compute
what's called a directional derivative
so i'll just write that out here so the
directional derivative
um
and essentially the directional
derivative is literally the derivative
the derivative of f my scalar function
f in a direction
v so this is kind of cool we're used to
being able to take
the derivative of our function in the x
direction that's just partial partial x
we're used to being able to take it in
the y direction that's partial partial y
but what if i say okay take it in this v
direction i've got some random vector
v how do i take the derivative of f the
rate of change of
f in that direction is f getting bigger
smaller
by how much and mathematically we say
that this is the directional derivative
of f in the v direction this is how we
write it it's the derivative of
f in the v direction and it's super
simple it doesn't get simpler than this
it's just v
dotted with the gradient of f
remember the gradient of f is a vector
and i can dot it into this direction
v so i literally just see like where is
that where is
you know grad t grad f pointing and i
dot it with v
and that tells me how fast and if
they're perpendicular
then the directional derivative is zero
actually i kind of drew it so that the
gradient is almost perpendicular to this
v
in which case the directional derivative
would be zero
which means if i take a small step in
that direction my temperature doesn't
change
there are directions like that and you
have to normalize by
the length of this v because someone
might give you like a v
that's 10 units long or 0.10 units long
and it shouldn't
matter what the length of v is so the
directional derivative also super
important
okay one more example i want to really
like drive home how much i love the
gradient
how useful it is and i feel like when
i'm learning
math i like to see it a lot of different
ways because maybe one of them clicks
so the gradient allows me to compute the
rate
of change of a scalar field in the x and
y
directions that's literally the rate of
change in the x direction the rate of
change in the y direction
it allows me to compute directions of
fastest rate of change
it also allows me to take the derivative
in any old direction
and uh another example of the gradient
beyond the temperature distribution is
uh
gravitational potentials okay so an
object
maybe i'll do a pink over here
so another application is an object
in a gravitational
field okay and i want to kind of try to
remember how to actually do this so
we have newton's law of gravity
okay and newton's law is something like
uh
the force and remember force has a
direction it's a vector
the force is equal to um if i have like
i should probably draw a planet here so
if i have planet earth
let's actually make this kind of fancy
right so we got some
some continents
really bad at drawing earth okay we've
got some continents over here
earth earth has a gravitational field
right
and that gravitational field always
points
towards the center of earth we know that
that's true and in fact
the gravitational field is stronger the
closer you are
if you go way way out i'll only have a
little force
a smaller force okay so it's always
pointing into the center
and it's bigger when you're closer and
you can write that down
newton's law as minus little
m times big m times the gravitational
constant
divided by the radius cubed times some
radius vector
where um how do i wanna say it so that's
if i have some point
out here with mass little m of course
earth has mass big m uh and this
r vector is always pointing towards the
center of the earth
okay this is always the vector pointing
towards the center of the earth
and this has magnitude r so
i need another r down here we know that
the force decreases as r squared
and then i need another r to counteract
the magnitude of this
and that's it the force always points in
the radial direction
and it has magnitude given by this
expression here
okay that's all fine and good this has
nothing to do with the gradient so far
except that this is a potential field
this is equal to
minus the gradient of the potential
energy of this object so any object at
some radius r is going to have a
potential energy
and its potential energy increases the
farther out you go in
r and literally the gradient of that
potential
is what gives rise to this uh this force
law here
where the gravitational potential
uh the gravitational potential v is
equal to
uh minus little m big m
big g over little r
um that's it literally the potential
increases as you
as you go farther away and
if you grab this object you arrive at
this
force law vector field so i highly
encourage you to actually do this
exercise
write this out in cartesian xy or xyz
coordinates
and compute its gradient and convince
yourself that it is actually the right
gravitational potential
okay very kind of useful idea
this is also useful if you have a roller
coaster on earth i love roller coasters
in fact i'm filming this at
7 00 pm the day before i'm about to move
across the country to california for
sabbatical
that's how much i love gradients and i
love teaching you about gradients
and on the way we're going to go to
santa cruz and we're going to ride
roller coasters at their fair
okay and the exact same
potential if i write the potential
energy of a car
on a roller coaster i can create a
vector field of the forces at every
point
on that roller coaster you know by by
creating the gradient
okay that's how gravity is acting on the
car
at all of those uh those locations okay
so this is the gradient we're gonna do
the same thing for
div and curl and then we're gonna start
putting these objects together and
showing how
these kind of partial derivatives and
these operators are the building blocks
of vector calculus conservation laws and
partial differential equations
all right thank you
[Music]
you